bitte was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir
haben sehr sehr lange keine geilen
restposten oder weiß nicht ob es gut
wäre ich hoffe mal auf jeden fall war
ich letztens wieder ein bisschen shoppen
habe was bestellt wir schauen uns das
ganz kurz an kleinen moment das ist
natürlich auch immer wieder so direkt
fünf tage her deswegen weiß ich gar
nicht mehr genau was wir da jetzt
eigentlich auspacken nur so ungefähr wie
ok bezahlt habe ich 150 euro für amazon
restposten paket 15 teile restposten
retouren artikel neuware und in bildern
konnte man eigentlich überhaupt nichts
annehmen ich gehe mal davon aus dass er
sich nicht selber gemacht hat auf dem
bild war auf jeden fall nur amazon
kartons das gute war aber der verkäufer
hatte 100 prozent positive bewertungen
dachte ich jetzt immer drauf weil wenn
du jemanden hast der 60 prozent als
brauchst nichts kaufen und deswegen gehe
ich auch heute mal mit einem guten
gefühl an die sache und wir checken mal
ob wir was brauchbares mit let's go also
leute ihr kennt das spiel ich mache
einfach direkt ohne jedoch groß herum zu
labern mal gucken
ich bin gespannt okay nicht eingepackt
ist es auf jeden fall schon mal ich habe
hier aktuell coop vanille aus holland
gekauft super lecker und das design
alter also tschuldigung das ist doch
einfach mal wild oder gebt euch das mal
und er schmeckt sehr lecker ist
natürlich kein fleisch
ok ach du scheiße junge wir machen eins
nach dem anderen ok eins nach dem
anderen leute also er hat ja dazu
geschrieben es sind 15 teile
es sieht schon mal hey das ist wohl so
meine kindheit ich habe das mal ein
bisschen zur seite wir starten wir hier
mit als erstes haben wir hier ok der
wird auf jeden fall schon mal ausgepackt
das ist ein playstation wenn ich mich
jetzt nicht ganz deutschland playstation
2 controller oder ist es ein playstation
3 controller das kann natürlich auch
sein
es ist kein originaler controller
besteht gar nichts na ja doch die marke
top way doppelstadt 2 verloren
ich glaube es ist ein ps3 controller
danke dafür auf jeden fall mega korrekt
auch weil ja für ps3 auch zocker zurzeit
also ps3 ist ja der neue schritt weiter
geht hiermit das habe ich gerade schon
gesagt das ist kristalle züchten kennt
man doch oder das kennt doch jeder okay
ich weiß nicht die kids von heutzutage
die kennen das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
wir kennen nur noch vorne züchten aber
das hier war so nett das gibt es schon
ewig ohne scheiß das gibst du schön
schon 20 jahre
du hast ja sonst chemiebaukasten mit bei
und kann es dann verschiedene form
züchten meine cousine hatte das früher
einmal genau und da durfte ich dann auch
mal mit züchten die kristalle habe das
dann auch mal mit begeisterung
wahrgenommen
deswegen weiß gar nicht was so etwas
kostet ihr seht die preise hier auch
immer eingeblendet und wir schauen was
am ende übrig bleibt ob ich mit diesen
150 euro plus machen oder eben nicht das
bekommt auf jeden fall einen ganz ganz
schönen platz hier neben den ganzen
iphones da sind übrigens dazu gekommen
die ich ja auch gekauft habe wenn ihr
das video noch nicht gesehen habe durch
die alten defekten und nicht defekten
iphones sich jetzt reparieren werde
ausgepackt habe checkt auf jeden fall
das letzte video weiter geht's mit einem
okay damit kann man auch arbeiten für
die streamer meldescheine ein recording
wmb professional das sieht schon ein
bisschen älter aus muss ich mal googeln
ich denke mal mehr als 20 euro wird das
nicht kosten aber immerhin und das ist
ja noch originalverpackt es ist halt nur
leider immer so ein bisschen ranzig wenn
diese karton farbe so total ausgleich
da weißt du schon okay die nachfrage für
dieses produkt geht gegen null
weiter gehts was haben wir noch was
haben wir noch hier haben wir led
tendler h okay das kenne ich auch ja ja
das habe ich schon öfter mal bei uns
bestellt früher das sind lampen da
kannst du ohne batterie rein pfeffern
und kannst du dann mit zum zelten bisher
an sich selbst erklären kann man so auf
hängen auch wichtig meine sogar die
warenmarkt kostenlos also du musst es
nur den versand bezahlen weil sie nicht
mehr ganz genau auch hierfür werde ich
nichts liegen das sind schon wieder du
produkte ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich auch
mal dieses 1100 euro amazon xxl unboxing
von mir gesehen viel ist einfach dabei
was china krams ist und so wirklich mal
was richtig heißes hatte ich ja noch nie
mache ich falsch
also zumindest was die amazon unboxing
sun geht weil noch nie irgendwas dabei
wo ich gesagt habe okay das ist
geisteskrank also nicht dass hier das
ist jetzt nicht geisteskrank
nicht mal was das ist apple watch ach so
okay das ist ein case für apple watches
black und einmal in roségold wunderbar
ok weiter geht's mit hier haben wir
einen kabellosen handstaubsauger kann
ich mich ganz gut aus also ja oh mann
nein das kann doch nicht wahr sein ich
erzähle meine geschichte das kannst hier
rein wollen das ist wirklich traurig mit
diesen handstaubsauger werden extrem
viele ältere menschen über den tisch
gezogen das ist eigentlich auch ein
bisschen traurig muss man sagen aber gut
ich habe eine tante die ist schon 78 und
dann habe ich noch meine beiden
großeltern die sind noch ein bisschen
älter und die haben sich letztens so ein
staubsauger kauft nicht von mir ich
hatte mal eigene verkauft die waren viel
viel besser als diese scheiß sänger und
die kosten auch auf amazon safe so 30
euro wohl ein paar habe ich glaube ich
sogar noch von meinen mein name auf
jeden fall auf 30 euro kostet und es
kamen einfach random so irgendwelche
leute zu denen nach hause haben
geklingelt und wollten den einen
staubsauger andrehen so ein staubsauger
sonnenähnlichen etwas bessere marke aber
für 140 euro
und was machen ältere leute in den
meisten fällen wenn ihnen was auf
gequatscht wird richtig sie kaufen ist
und meine tante hatte lässt uns zum
staubsauger darum sind den hat sie an
der haustür gekauft für 140 euro
da habe ich mich gefragt also ohne
scheiß 110 euro hätte ich in müll getan
und von den anderen 30 euro hätte ich
ihr dann genau den gleichen stoff wir
ungefähr
und das ist wirklich ein bisschen
traurig deswegen so viel zu der story
mit dem handstaubsauger machen wir
weiter hier mit was haben wir denn hier
motion sensor ah ok es gibt wirklich
nichts was es nicht gibt
das kann ich immer wieder sage nein
motion sensor den kann man an die decke
hängen in die 8 hier sind sogar bilder
drauf was haben wir denn hier einmal in
der garage dann im flur vor der haustür
wieder im flur da kannst du diesen
sensor anbringen ich hoffe der
funktioniert noch weil ich glaube so was
ist denke ich mal gar nicht so günstig
ihr seid auf den preis dafür wieder hier
eingeblendet und jetzt kommen wir sogar
noch zu sachen mit denen ich etwas
anfangen können also die werde ich
direkt in mein auto schmeißen mit nach
hause nehmen weil ohne scheiß ich habe
zwei schwämme insgesamt sind es
wahrscheinlich viel das ist auf jeden
fall super korrekt weil ich hatte heute
morgen keine mehr und ich wollte gleich
noch einkaufen gehen und immer wieder
sowie gene zeugs kaufen wenn man kann
ich mir auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal
sparen das ist echt immer so lustig
hatte das schon so oft dass ich in
diesen restposten paketen irgendwas drin
hatte wo ich noch am vortag gedacht
haben scheiße das musst du dir mal
wieder kaufen dann haben wir hier noch
und noch ein fahrradschlauch und ans
netz gmbh amstad gmbh die kenne ich
geil und zu guter letzt von toshiba noch
eine sd-karte 16 gb und das hier lineal
liga man schadet ja wir haben hier noch
zwei lineale und wollte nochmal genauer
darauf eingehen dass hier ist von der am
slip gmbh also halb amazon halb amazon
fbl deutschland läuft über die ems lab
gmbh das waren auch die kann ich jetzt
mal sagen wo ich irgendwann mal
testweise bestellt habe und dann habe
ich immer amazon paketen nach hause
bekommen die ich halt gar nicht bestellt
habe ich muss sagen aktuell kommen keine
mehr es ist bestimmt jetzt schon
mindestens fünf monate her dass ich das
letzte mal irgendwas von amazon.com was
ich nicht bestellt habe also das hat
leider aufgehört weil diese videos vor
allem war echt lustig wenn man so sachen
aufgemacht hat die man gar nicht
bestellt hat eigentlich ein bisschen
schade
naja kann man nichts machen ich werde
das ganze jetzt noch mal eben
zusammenrechnen ihr könnt man die
kommentare schreiben
ob ich in zukunft noch weitere amazon
restposten pakete bestellen soll aber im
großen und ganzen zumindest bei den
verkäufern bei denen ich bestellt aber
meistens nur rods drin
es ist auch ein bisschen schade und hier
wirklich die sache mit dem
handstaubsauger die geht mir persönlich
sehr sehr nahe
naja abschließend kann man ja sagen dass
diese handstaubsauger hier liegt schon
mal ein vorteil er kann nicht mehr
irgendwelche senioren für 100 euro
angeboten wenn das leute was geht ich
bin gerade im urlaub in griechenland ich
habe vergessen weil noch zu sagen wie
viel wert denn das ganze sein soll also
das paket war auf jeden fall ein flop
wenn man alles addiert man sogar 280
euro aber kann es eigentlich vergessen
meinen die meisten sachen davon sind ja
auch alle schon ein bisschen älter
ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
bald kommen auf jeden fall auf wieder
geil an bord von videos auch das iphone
riesling geht ja weiter deswegen was
gern nach oben da seid gespannt ich bin
ich noch zwei tage lang jetzt weiter mit
vielen videos sollte haut rein